voglio raccontarvi una storia è a dir la
verità è una storia un po speciale
perché pensate e lunga centinaia di
migliaia di anni e a questo punto vedo
già qualcuno tra il pubblico soprattutto
qui vicino che vi vedo meglio
preoccupato all'idea le centinaia di
migliaia di anni ma non vi preoccupate
perché io qui ho il timer mi dice che ho
quindici minuti massimo quindi cercherò
di essere sintetica tranquilli
oltre a essere così lunga però è anche
nata avuto origine su quello che una
persona molto più saggia di me car saga
noto astrofisico statunitense una volta
dei fini con una frase che a mio parere
davvero molto poetica definì come un
minuscolo granello di polvere
sospeso in un raggio di sole
ma poi non è solo questa storia perché è
anche la storia di una bambina una
bambina che guarda con emozione e con
trepidazione quegli infiniti puntini
luminosi accendersi tutte le sere sopra
la sua testa e della storia di tutti
coloro che prima o dopo di lei hanno
guardato guarderanno almeno una volta
nella loro vita
l'infinita bellezza di quel cielo che ci
avvolge e ci travolge
a questo punto però ho due notizie una
buona e l'altra cattiva quella cattiva è
che vi ho promesso di raccontarvi una
storia ma la verità è che io non conosco
il finale di questa storia e quindi di
nuovo qui dirà qualcuno di voi ed ai
meno male così andiamo brevi ma c'è
anche una buona notizia e la buona
notizia è che anche se non conosco il
finale della storia per fortuna posso
sognarlo e quindi chiederei a tutti voi
sia voi che siete qui presenti in teatro
oggi sia voi che invece ci guardate
guarderete da casa in streaming non lo
so di chiudere per per un momento gli
occhi e di sognare insieme a me
non so se la conoscete ma esiste una
famosa leggenda metropolitana nata negli
anni trenta del secolo scorso che dice
secondo le leggi della fisica il
calabrone non può volare ma questo lui
non lo sa e quindi vola lo stesso
allo stesso modo quando quella bambina
osserva le stelle e le persone che
chiedono perché le piacciono così tanto
lei non lo sa ma continua a guardare lo
stesso perché è difficile dare una
spiegazione a una passione che nasce da
dentro il cui fuoco brucia ardentemente
giorno dopo giorno
e difficile trovare le parole che
possano anche solo lontanamente
esprimere il mondo che quella bambina
sente dentro quando appunto guarda le
stelle
che poi però se ci pensate la passione
di quella bambina la sua curiosità la
voglia di scoprire cosa c'è oltre quelli
infinita distesa azzurra che di giorno
ci colora la vita e che di notte ci fa
fare i sogni più belli
affondano le loro radici in tempi
lontanissimi e sono le stesse che da
sempre muovono il genere umano verso
l'oltre
i millenni di storia infatti l'uomo
occupò prima la terra e questo forse in
un qualche modo più semplice poi
vincendo le paure conquistò anche i mari
spingendosi per la prima volta oltre le
mitiche colonne d'ercole che
rappresentavano un po quelli
invalicabile confine del mondo mondo che
poi in realtà li non finiva ma
continuava e continua va pensate un po
per lanciare nuove sfide fine che
appunto furono vinte da grandi
esploratori colombo vespucci magellano
in generale potremmo dire tutte quelle
persone che videro con i loro occhi i
cieli nuovi di terre nuove
a questo punto dopo aver parlato di
terra dopo aver parlato di mare è lecito
chiedersi non c'è nient'altro da
conquistare
beh rimaneva l'aria il sogno del volo il
più grande e il più pauroso e più
sfidante
immaginate di essere come gli uccelli di
poter toccare con mano le nuvole di
sfidare gli dei che avevano casa proprio
lì in quel cielo
ecco qual era l'ardimento più grande è
la sfida più grande per l'uomo di quel
tempo vi chiederete impossibile beh
direi che per nostra fortuna nulla o
quasi è impossibile alla determinazione
della volontà umana che inventò le
macchine volanti e occupo come gli
uccelli l'aria
magari non era ancora tutto perché fuori
c'era l'infinito altrove dello spazio la
vera frontiera
la pagina bianca di una storia che sarà
potenzialmente infinita
oggi dopo circa 60 anni forse anche
qualcosina di più direi dal periodo
della corsa allo spazio durante la
guerra fredda tra stati uniti unione
sovietica
oggi viviamo finalmente una nuova luce
per l'esplorazione dello spazio siamo
all'alba di una nuova luce per
l'esplorazione spaziale
una luce che ci consentirà di andare più
lontano di quanto siano mai stati o di
quanto abbiamo mai creduto possibile
una luce che per noi è importante perché
porta con sé tutti i successi tutti i
fallimenti tutti gli sforzi e tutte le
vittorie che i millenni di storia
abbiamo collezionato come genere umano
che alla fine se ci pensate non è altro
che una specie qualunque nata e
sviluppatasi per citare nuovamente car
side anche come avete capito mi piace
molto nate e sviluppatesi su un piccolo
puntino bloom che da miliardi di anni
balla un armonioso valzer attorno al
sole
una specie qualunque questo è vero ma ha
da sempre mosso i propri passi come
spinta da una naturale curiosità verso
tutto ciò che è ignoto una curiosità non
da poco perché ci ha permesso di
inventare la scrittura di scoprire la
penicillina e in ultimo di andare nello
spazio
una curiosità che alla fine rende la
nostra specie una specie unica e che io
spero mi auguro per davvero possa non
abbandonarci mai
e devo dire che è proprio sulle tracce
di questa curiosità che io sono più
emozionata che mai
l'idea di vivere agli albori di una
nuova era d'oro per l'esplorazione dello
spazio
penso che in generale sia proprio questo
concetto di alba ad emozionarmi ma in
fondo a chi di noi non emozione un'alba
pensate quel momento in cui tutto inizia
e non sappiamo ancora che cosa sarà
magari quel qualcosa deve ancora nascere
ma impotenza la possibilità di essere
tutto
ecco io questo lo trovo veramente molto
eccezionale
un po come l'alba di ogni nuovo giorno
alla fine quel momento appunto in cui
tutto inizia in cui tutto può ancora
cambiare
quell'attimo sospeso in cui solo noi
effettivamente siamo i padroni di noi
stessi e del nostro tempo in cui solo
noi possiamo scegliere di prendere in
mano le redini della nostra vita
e quindi è proprio sulle tracce di
questa lva che posso vedere molti
metaforicamente come momento in cui io
decido di prendere in mano le redini
della mia vita che a 22 anni ho un sogno
studio fisica all'università di torino
per cercare di inseguire questo sogno è
il mio sogno quale beh il mio sogno è
quello di poter partecipare anche io in
qualche modo a quello che sarà il
progresso scientifico e tecnologico del
futuro che poi non mi piace mai parlare
solo di progetto scientifico e
tecnologico perché sembra sempre
qualcosa di un pò fine a se stesso ma in
realtà io sono fortemente convinta che
scienza e tecnologia in realtà non siano
altro che progresso umano perché alla
fine siamo noi esseri umani a fare quel
progresso e quindi ecco che la scienza
la tecnologia ci consentono di
progredire in avanti come specie
devo dire che poi io sono sempre stata
una persona che non ha mai amato
partecipare passivamente diciamo alle
cose che le accadono attorno sempre
preferito in qualche modo mettere le
mani in pasta come si suol dire ed è
così che appunto tre anni fa ho
partecipato insieme a un amico a un
concorso indetto dall'agenzia spaziale
europea e devo dire che partecipato a
questo concorso ma in realtà senza
nessuna aspettativa il bando era aperto
da maggio e io quando l'ho scoperto era
luglio luglio 2018 me la metà luglio
mancavano due settimane alla scadenza io
ho chiamato questo mi micro ho detto
senti che ne dici partecipiamo tanto non
abbiamo assolutamente nulla da perdere
ci impegniamo ci divertiamo impariamo
cose nuove
scopriamo cose nuove impariamo che alla
fine la cosa più importante soprattutto
se penso quando si è giovani non può in
generale nella vita bisogna non smettere
mai di imparare ecco questo mio amico mi
ha detto sì dài proviamo e quindi per
due settimane abbiamo lavorato a questo
a questo progetto consistente nel
trovare un utilizzo alternativo aldrin
chaser il green chaser è un veicolo
spaziale che voi potete vedere
immaginare come un piccolo space shuttle
di dimensioni ovviamente molto ridotte è
stato sviluppato dalla sierra nevada
corporation questa compagnia
aerospaziale privata americana è compito
di questo green chaser sarà quello di
portare astronauti e cargo a bordo della
stazione spaziale internazionale del
prossimo futuro noi abbiamo trovato un
utilizzo alternativo e abbiamo pensato
di utilizzarlo come sorta di ponte tra
le emissioni qui sulla terra e quelle di
più lontane nello spazio quindi per
esempio sulla luna o sugli asteroidi
perché no ecco pensate che il nostro
progetto alla fine è risultato quello
vincitore in quel momento
grazie
[Applauso]
in quel momento quando il nostro
progetto il risultato appunto quello
vincitore la mia felicità a in un
qualche modo toccato le stelle ma non
tanto per la vittoria in sé perché
quella serata bella è stata una grande
soddisfazione assolutamente non posso
negarlo ma quel momento è stato per me è
importante perché io ho capito che
allora non ci sono limiti ai sogni e che
tutto in un qualche modo sì si può
concretizzare quello che è ovviamente
necessario avere e determinazione
passione impegno costanza a volte fare
dei sacrifici e perché no anche versare
qualche lacrima quella purtroppo a volte
capita
grazie
io oggi oltre a studiare fisica
all'università mi occupo anche di
divulgazione scientifica per ragazzi
parlo loro di scienza in particolare gli
spazi perché come avrete capito
probabilmente la mia passione e parlo
loro con l'idea di poterli appassionare
incuriosire o anche solo semplicemente
ispirare devo dire che a volte davvero
molto difficile portare avanti questi
due impegni parallelamente perché
comunque richiedono molto del mio tempo
e sembra sempre che di tempo non ce ne
sia mai abbastanza
quindi tante volte ho pensato non ce la
faccio forse sarebbe meglio mollare
tutto no ma poi ogni volta che un
bambino mi si è avvicinato e mi ha detto
da grande e io voglio essere come te ho
capito che allora quello è il mio posto
e che io non potrei farne a meno perché
alla fine questa è la vita che ho scelto
chiaramente oggi non so non posso ancora
sapere dove mi porterà la vita o di
fronte a quali sfide mi metterà davanti
non so cosa farò dove sarò domani tra
una settimana o tra tre anni ma quello
che so con estrema certezza è che ho
fame di futuro e non ho alcuna voglia di
accontentarmi
voglio continuare a studiare
impegnarmi perché questa è l'unica
ricetta che ad oggi conosco per poter
continuare a mirare alle stelle e chi lo
sa perché no magari un giorno anche
avvicinarmi a loro con una tuta da
astronauta addosso
grazie
perché appunto 22 anni ma una cosa penso
di averla capita nella vita in generale
bisogna sempre puntare all'impossibile
per poter toccare anche solo
metaforicamente le stelle con un dito
grazie